foreign
the New York Times uh reported basically
raccoon dogs for the win it's their
fault coveted 19 SARS cov2 it's it's the
raccoon dogs after all but not frozen
this time no not frozen it's the fall of
those crazy Chinese people who trade
them now now it's not racist right to
blame the Chinese people and their trade
of wildlife that they definitely
shouldn't be trading now now this is The
Honorable thing so the New York Times
in their article headlined new data
links pandemics Origins to raccoon dogs
Wuhan Market which came out on the 16th
March 16th two days ago the first
paragraph reads an international team of
virus experts
an international team of virus experts
said on Thursday that they had found
genetic data from a market in Wuhan
China linking the coronavirus with
raccoon dogs for sale there adding
evidence to the case that the worst
pandemic in a century could have been
ignited by an infected animal that was
being dealt through the illegal Wildlife
trade
and you have to go down pretty far in
the article to discover that the players
involved are a lot of the same players
that we've become familiar with now it's
Christian Anderson leading up the team
he's one of the international members of
the international team of virus experts
and then you have playing sort of well
wingman to the wingman is Angela
Rasmussen
um and it's just you know the same
people with the same conclusions over
and over and over again and this New
York Times article is actually
particularly bad but as it turns out
laser Spartan most of it from the
Atlantic so we've talked before about
the Atlantic monthlies reporting on SARS
Kobe 2 which has been abominable and
they've got this small team of three or
four happens to be all women reporters
that are just doing this like gossipy
coffee clutch stuff that sort of sounds
sciency but really never is
the Abominable Snow Job
abominable snow job Indeed
um so it's one of them again in the
Atlantic writing
um and so we talked about this
explicitly uh in November of 2021 on
episode 105 what's going on at the
Atlantic but they are still at it so
here I'm going to and again wish I could
show you my screen here but we do just
some highlighted sections from the
Atlantic article
called the strongest evidence yet that
an animal started the pandemic a new
analysis of genetic samples from China
appears to link the pandemic's origin to
raccoon dogs by Catherine J Wu this was
published somehow the same day as the
New York Times article was published
even though the New York Times cites the
Atlantic as having been the source of
this so see earlier point about the
weird coordination across institutions
yes indeed updated
um the following day that is to say
yesterday March 17th I don't know what
was updated
um but you know there's this whole piece
is
worth reading if you can stomach it but
I've just I'm just going to read the
highlighted the pieces that I've
highlighted here
this oh actually I'll I'll start with
you know what is the evidence anyway
like what has happened that we are now
so certain that it's raccoon dogs of
notic origin right this must be powerful
evidence oh it's powerful it's going to
be powerful for three years now the
Oracle Begins the debate this is the
article by Wu in the Atlantic Monthly
published this week for three years now
the debate over the origins of the
coronavirus pandemic has ping-ponged
between two big ideas that SARS kovi 2
spilled into human populations directly
from wild animal source and that the
pathogen leaked from a lab through a
swirl of data obfuscation by Chinese
authorities and political
politicalization within the United
States and rampant speculation from all
corners of the world many scientists
have stood by the notion of this
outbreak like most others had purely
natural roots
but that hypothesis has been missing a
key piece of proof genetic evidence from
the Hunan Seafood wholesale Market in
Wuhan China showing that the virus had
infected creatures for sale there now an
international team of virologists
genomicists and evolutionary biologists
may have finally found crucial data help
fill that knowledge Gap a new analysis
of genetic sequences collected from the
market shows that raccoon dogs being
illegally sold at the venue could have
been carrying and possibly shutting the
virus at the end of 2019. let me just
slow down here a new analysis of genetic
sequences collected from the market
shows that
raccoon dogs being illegally sold at the
venue could have been carrying and
possibly shutting the virus at the end
of 2019.
wait okay it's some of the strongest
support yet experts told me that the
pandemic began when SARS Kobe 2 hopped
from animals into humans rather than in
an accident among scientists
experimenting viruses this really
strengthens the case for a natural
origin says SEMA lachtawala apologies
for their pronunciation a virologist at
Emory University who wasn't involved in
the research Angela Rasmussen a
urologist involved the research told me
this is a really strong indication that
animals at the market were infected
there's really no other explanation that
makes any sense really Angie
should I go on do you want to enter
interest first before there are a couple
there's a lot more to say but yeah um
one the idea that this is the strongest
evidence yet may actually be true even
though there is really essentially no
evidence here other than the presence of
the animal and the location that they
want us to believe it started in and
there's some
will get here but there's some sequences
that have
um the you know the Genome of the
raccoon dog and um The genome of the
virus that show up in the same place
right
right at the same time
ish right the kind of evidence that
implies that the people in the World
Trade Center may have brought it down
themselves because their DNA was present
in the crime scene but you know but also
notice the linguistic turn of phrase
there where the point is what we've been
waiting for is evidence that it came
from the Wuhan lab I mean the the Wuhan
seafood market yes yes that is the piece
that is missing that is the piece and
there's so much here
like as far as I can tell like this is
this is the scientific evidence at this
point there's not even a freaking paper
to look at oh there's nothing it's not
it's not oh it's only on a pre-print
server like no it doesn't exist yet well
it doesn't exist yet and yet you have
two major Publications trumpeting it and
we've seen this before with covet we saw
this with the together trial that
supposedly uh showed that Ivermectin was
ineffective against covet where we had
that result six months before we were
able to look at the methodology of the
paper that was trumpeted in major
headlines and so this is not even unpeer
reviewed right you've got peer-reviewed
where something has been scrutinized and
then it is presented to the public
you've got unpreer-reviewed where it's
put on a pre-print server and nobody has
scrutinized it ahead of time
so that other scientists and anyone else
who wants to can assess yes there's no
assessment possible it's not well the
point is what they've done is they've
decided to give us the conclusion in
advance of us being able to scrutinize
how they reached it which suggests that
that conclusion may not be based on a
robust methodology why would they want
to do that though why would they want to
start with a conclusion well possible
interest could they have in starting
with the conclusion interesting now some
people will remember that Christian
Anderson was in fact initially the
person who called Anthony fauci's
attention to the fact that the Genome of
the virus in question was in his words
inconsistent with predictions from
evolutionary theory from a natural
origin
without you then in some way if you've
seen the light well he has seen he has
seen the light for those of you just
listening I'm making that gesture that
people make when they're handling money
um
does anyone actually do that with money
though
I have never seen film of Christian
Anderson doing this but there is
actually evidence of a tremendous amount
of money having flowed to him to his
boss Eric tople yes that Eric tople at
the Scripps Institute that's an expert I
can really get behind trusting can't you
um I am I am somewhat behind in trusting
Eric topel I just think he may have a
conflict of interest
um the size of a you know the
International Space Station but
um but anyway the idea that we are being
told you know that you have multiple
journalistic sources that are reporting
it's so urgent yeah it's so urgent that
we know the conclusion from this study
that they have to publish on it before
we're even allowed to look at it well
that department of energy stuff that
came out and said like actually we're
not sure at all but like it really kind
of seems like it could be a lab leak
they they had to get right on top of
that so here we have these sort of
glowing endorsements in pseudosciency
language uh and you know the I don't
know the I'm not I have never run into
as far as I know before the work of the
author of The New York Times piece but
this like
the Atlantic just created this stable of
pseudoscience journalists reporting on
pseudoscience that did their work over
and over and over and over again during
this pandemic during the whole for the
last three years and they just haven't
veered they just have not looked outside
of their little their Lane yeah they
picked the lane and they are staying in
it and there's nothing to indicate that
that lane is reflective of reality or
truth shall I read a few more bits from
absolutely
it's a long article
um
the genetic sequences were pulled out of
swabs taken in a near-market stalls
around the pandemic start so that's the
source of the evidence
the new analysis led by Christian
Anderson Edward Holmes and Michael Warby
three prominent researchers who have
been looking into the virus's roots
shows that that may not be the
case that not may not be the case being
um
uh sorry uh no animal host for stars
Kobe 2 can be deduced within about half
a day of downloading the data from
gisaid this is not a database I am
familiar with and so I'm not actually
sure how it's normally pronounced but
gisaid
it's an Open Access genomic database was
Data were posted there and this team
happened to get lucky and pull it and
then the data disappeared again and no
one can figure out what's going on there
so that also is strange maybe everyone
just got lucky
Maybe
within about half a day of downloading
the data from gisaid the trio and their
collaborators discovered that several
Market samples that tested positive for
SARS Kobe 2 were also coming back chock
full of animal genetic material much of
which was a match with a common raccoon
dog a small animal related to foxes that
has a raccoon-like face
finding the genetic material of virus
and mammals so closely commingled enough
to be extracted out of a single swab
isn't perfect proof Lochte Walla told me
it's an important step I'm not going to
diminish that she said still the
evidence falls short of say isolating
SARS Kobe 2 from a free-ranging raccoon
dog or even better uncovering a viral
sample swab from a mammal for sale at
Hunan from the time of the outbreaks
onset
still the findings don't stand alone
do I believe there were infected animals
at the market yes I do Anderson told me
so this is just a statement of belief
it's not based it's it's simply a
statement of belief it's a statement of
belief do I believe there are infected
animals at the market yes I do Anderson
told me does this new data add to that
evidence base yes end quote the new
analysis Builds on extensive previous
research that points to the market as
the source of the earliest major
outbreak of SARS cov2 colon here's the
evidence she's going to trot out many of
the earliest known covid-19 cases the
pandemic were clustered roughly in the
Market's vicinity
roughly
and the viruses
genetic material was found in many
sample swab from carts and animal
processing equipment at the venue as
well as parts of nearby infrastructure
such as storehouses sewage Wells and
water drains that's
two pieces of evidence neither of which
are evidence not extensive research
raccoon dogs creatures commonly bred for
sale in China are also already known to
be one of many mammal species that can
easily catch and spread the coronavirus
all of this left one main hole in the
puzzle to fill
clear-cut evidence the raccoon dogs and
the virus were in the exact same spot at
the market close enough that the
creatures might have been infected and
possibly infectious that's what the new
analysis provides
they could really really someone who
understands anything
about evolution
or how viruses might actually move
between species don't you think no I
think that would screw up their whole
plan of selling us the idea that the
seafood market is the likeliest origin
of the human pandemic all of this left
one main hole in the puzzle to fill
okay think of it as finding the DNA of
an investigation's main suspect at the
scene of the cross
the findings don't rule out the
possibilities other animals may have
been carrying SARS Kobe 2 at Juan on
raccoon dogs if they were infected may
not even be the creatures who pass the
pathogen onto US
well then why are we talking about them
okay that's not in the article I'm
editorializing now which means the
search for the viruses many wild hosts
will need to plot on
do we know the intermediate host with
raccoon dogs no Anderson wrote to me
using the term for an animal that can
vary a pathogen between other species is
it high up on my list of potential hosts
yes but it's definitely not the only one
so now we're kind of backing off from
this giant like oh the New York Times
the Atlantic Monthly is going to tell us
that now we have this evidence it's
raccoon dogs raccoon dogs well except
maybe not but it could be so we've now
backed off two-thirds of the way or so
through this article too yeah maybe but
isn't this cool
at this point it's still unclear why the
sequences were so recently posted to
gisaid they also vanished from the
database shortly after the international
team of researchers notified the Chinese
researchers of their preliminary
findings without explanation
I go on and on and on there's really no
explanation
Skeptics
will likely be eager to poke holes on
the team's new findings
pointing out I don't think they need to
be poked I think there are plenty of
holes in those findings they don't
require any of us like
we've been sure enough we've had nothing
shared with us there's no findings
except that we've been told
we've been told swabs had DNA from the
raccoon dogs and uh genetic sequences
from the virus in close proximity in a
market where sick people undoubtedly
co-mingled with animals that they were
buying you sound like a skeptic
Skeptics will likely be eager to poke
holes in the team's new findings
pointing out for instance this is
technically possible for genetic
material from viruses and animals stand
up sloshed together in the environment
even if an infection didn't take place
maybe an infected human visited the
market and inadvertently deposited viral
RNA near an animal's crate how dare they
but an infected animal with no
third-party contamination still seems by
far the most plausible explanation for
the samples genetic contents several
experts told me
other scenarios require contortions of
logic and more important additional
proof
I got if we're almost there all right
the debate over SARS Kobe 2's Origins
has raged for nearly as long as the
pandemic itself
okay I don't even get the rest of the
sentence outlasting lockdowns widespread
masking even the first version of the
covid-19 of the coveted vaccines
now what that's doing there and as long
as there is murkiness to cling to it may
never fully resolve
when President Joe Biden asked the U.S
intelligence Community to review the
matter for government agencies and the
National Intelligence Council pointed to
a natural origin while two others
guessed that it was a lab leak
okay
finally into this
crap piece in the Atlantic if this new
level of scientific evidence does
conclusively tip the origins debate
toward the animal route it will be in
one way a major letdown
it will mean that SARS Kobe 2 breached
our borders because we once again
mismanaged our relationship with
wildlife
that we failed to prevent this epidemic
for the same reason we failed and could
fail again to prevent so many of the
rest oh I frankly I predicted that
if they manage to sell us on this story
that this has a natural origin then the
point is the lesson of the pandemic is
the inverse not you must not do the kind
of research that turns the world upside
down but in fact you have to do more of
that research because we missed it you
know by this much we were studying these
viruses but we didn't get ahead of this
thing and it got us anyway so next time
we need to have done much more of this
gain of function research in order to be
ready that's what they're going to sell
us it's even worse than that oh yeah all
right my turn yeah yeah no so that for
sure but also don't go into nature that
it's dangerous there's wild things out
there and they will give you diseases
stay inside be safe it's clean we've got
some antibacterial spray for you
antiviral spray anti-everything spray
you just get right in that comfortable
little zone of yours will stream some
crap into your face that you can watch
and be entertained by but for God's sake
don't go outside stay yes Don't Unplug
from our mechanism of narrative control
so I wanted to give an interpretation
you you wondered about their claim of
the uh natural origin having outlasted
something something about uh it just
back themes Mass
et cetera Etc it's just a weird thing to
well but no I know what they're getting
at okay
in this case the day is a she well it's
part of the bigger C earlier Point
regarding the emergent nature of the the
day she uh complex that advances the
phony narrative uh we have to talk about
cats again are we no no no for the
moment no no we're on to
um raccoon dogs having uh wait did they
have pronouns too you'll have to ask
them but I will say that this is a major
Leap Forward from the Frozen ferret
Badger Stakes uh that they failed to
convince us we're the source of the
Great Leap Forward and talking about the
origins of this virus
I guess I mean you know
um make of it what you will okay but uh
okay but what really is going on here is
there a couple of narratives that are
disproportionately important and this is
a subtle point I think but
in some cases
we have succeeded in staring down their
garbage narratives right safe and
effective is not a phrase you hear
regularly used about the vaccines
anymore we're into much more nuanced
territory we're still lagging behind the
reality of what is apparent in the data
but nonetheless but there are certain
um
they are there are certain narratives
with uh an undead nature to them right
and I in fact would call the kind of
Journalism that you're talking about
instead of burying the lead it's
exhuming the lead they keep resurrecting
uh their lead their lead because they
cannot afford to have it die right to
the extent that the world is keeps
discovering I mean we keep getting new
agencies uh you know people who were on
the commission who uh you know Jeffrey
Sachs uh has announced that he saw
nothing but corruption in the commission
that was trying to find the origins
we've got all of these things that would
ordinarily cause a regular person to say
you know what that Wuhan seafood market
uh explanation
turned out to be nuts all sorts of
people with all sorts of different kinds
of expertise have converged on the idea
that this does seem to have emerged from
the lab right there in Wuhan
um Etc outbreak of chocolatey goodness
right
um but
the point is they can't afford to let it
go and it I don't think that they think
they're going to win this one but I
think what they have to do is muddle it
right this is a this is the doubt
component of a fear uncertainty and
doubt campaign the point is they need to
have some alternative That Remains live
so that the people who have been so
thoroughly embarrassed by the failure of
that garbage narrative have something to
say oh I'm on team Atlantic New York
Times right I mean don't you know that
they found the DNA of the you know uh
they found the DNA of the raccoon dogs
along with genetic material from SARS
Kobe 2 which of course if you're paying
attention you know that at the point
that these things are being swabbed for
in the Wuhan seafood market likely the
disease had been circulating in Wuhan
since September or October of 2019 it's
no surprise that there was SARS cov2 uh
all over the Wuhan seafood market which
means it's going to be co-mingled with
every single organism that was in that
market right there's no evidence here
um
and you know much less something that
they would let us scrutinize but but the
point is that narrative and the
Ivermectin turned out not to work
narrative these are two narratives that
they are never going to let die doesn't
matter what the evidence says they need
both of them right and they've got
um
they've got Confederates like
raspberries and saying this is a really
strong indication that animals that the
market were infected there's really no
other explanation that makes any sense
this is As credentialed on point a
scientist as you could possibly be who
has made a statement that is so
utterly and transparently ludicrous
and yet here it is here it is in the
Atlantic that statement makes no sense
and yet that that Authority saying it
will be sufficient for some number of
people right and it sounds so full of
meaning no other explanation makes sense
how about somebody with covid cough near
a raccoon dot I mean how about even in
this terrible article there's there's
other things like even this terrible
article presents others cannot manage to
not admit that actually yes this isn't
the only possibility even Christian
Andersen says
this isn't this isn't Clear Proof yeah
it's the weakest of tea and you know
what's more you know here's some strong
evidence we haven't found the wild
circulating pandemic in any creature let
alone raccoon dogs
foreign
[Music]